- [Tiffany] How to build a multi-agent
role-playing Game Master
with Strands Agent.
Quick question right before starting.
Like, raise your hand if you know
what is a role-playing tabletop game.
- [Olivier] Who's played it?
- [Tiffany] Okay.
- [Olivier] Few people
don't, so if you wanna
make introduction.
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
Most people know, that's cool.
Sometimes we play this presentation
in different countries,
and depending on cultures,
maybe sometimes people don't know.
- [Olivier] I see some people
didn't raise their hand,
so if you want to make a brief-
- [Tiffany] Yeah, yeah.
So,
a tabletop role-playing game is,
you might have heard of Dungeons & Dragons
or games like this.
So basically, this is...
How can I...
Like, this is an open world
with a universe that already exists,
that has a playbook, like a
rule book that you can read.
It's like 400, I think, pages long.
And basically, you can
play in this universe
where you can play, like
for example, elves, orcs.
- [Olivier] Druids.
- [Tiffany] Yeah, dwarves,
and have your own characters,
and you can play a campaign.
And for example, you have
what we call a Dungeon Master.
So the role of the Dungeon
Master or the Game Master
is to build a campaign
to embark the players into
a story in this universe.
And the idea of this project
was because I am myself a
Dungeons & Dragon player,
and I sometimes have
troubles finding Game Masters
because it's really hard to
be a Game Master, actually.
You need to know all of
the rules of the game.
You need to know a lot
of things to be able to
drive your players into a campaign.
And I was thinking
that maybe artificial
intelligence could be cool,
a cool tool to help Game
Masters in assisting them,
and we'll see today how we can build
a multi-agent workflow for this.
So first, I will introduce
you the concept of agents.
At the very beginning
of when generative AI
became very public...
I don't know if you
remember, because I remember
the announcement was made during ReInvent.
It was three years ago for...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
For the well-known, like, ChatGPT.
But generative AI existed before that,
but it became well known
by the public by this day
because it was a tool that suddenly
everybody could use and
see the power of it.
So you could chat with those LLMs.
You can have a conversation
with them, but this is about it.
When you chat with an LLM,
you can have a conversation.
This is very powerful, but
what you'd want is also
this LLM to be able to
perform actions for you,
and this is where agents come into play.
Agents have agency.
That's why we call them agents.
They're able to make actions for you.
And the way they do those actions
is because they have access to tools.
Tools can be a lot of different things.
They can be APIs.
They can be functions.
They can be databases.
They can also be other agents
that also themselves have
access to other tools.
So you can see how this can
build up pretty quickly.
Usually, like in...
There's no standard,
really, but at the moment,
when you have multiple
agents working together,
you usually have one orchestrator
that has access to multiple
agents that each are specialized
and experts into a certain
task or a certain field.
One example that I like to give
sometimes is when you want,
for example, a coach, a
studying coach for a student,
you'll have the coach
that might be connected
to a team of different agents
that are all experts in different fields,
in math, in physics, in
history, in geographics.
And so you have all of your different ages
that are all of the teachers, for example.
And whenever your student
has a question to the coach
or maybe is asking for a set of exercises
or maybe questions about something,
then the orchestrator
redirects the questions
to the right expert, to the right agent
to be able to perform to answer the query.
So,
yes, to connect those tools...
Oh, so sorry.
To connect the tools with the agent,
we have what we call the protocol MCP.
So MCP stands for model context protocol.
You might have heard of it
because it's been doing this
this boom for this entire year.
So basically, this protocol standardizes
the way your agents can discover tools,
basically.
It's like REST for AI agents.
If you've tried to build
agents before with tools
before the MCP protocol,
maybe if you remember,
but it was pretty complex.
You had to maintain the way
you'd connect to the tool,
for example, a function.
There was no standardized way of doing it.
So, I mean, you were the only one
who was maintaining this whole workflow.
And in the same time, you weren't able,
unless you were talking to that person,
but you weren't able to connect to a tool
that someone else would have built.
And the power of MCP is that now,
if someone builds a tool
and puts it on a server,
on a certain endpoint,
and give it to you, then
you, on the other side,
with your agent, is able
to connect to that tool.
This is making things very powerful
'cause now, a lot of people
are creating a lot of tools,
and with your agent, you are
capable of using their tools.
And also, there is another protocol
that has been very famous
also for this year.
It's A2A, which stands for agent to agent,
and this protocol standardizes
the way agent connects to other agents.
So, two very different things.
One protocol is to connect to tools,
and the other protocol
is to connect to agents.
Why are those protocols different?
Because the way they
communicate is different.
Between agents, you need to be
able to build a conversation.
They both have a thought process.
They both have
planning,
and so they need to be able
to have this conversation.
Meanwhile, for a tool,
you don't necessarily
need to talk with it.
Actually, they don't have
this thought process.
The tools are just, like,
functions, or API calls, or databases,
so they're just gonna
give you an information.
They are going to perform
an action for you,
but that's pretty much it.
So for...
Oh, yeah.
Oops, sorry.
So basically,
to sum it up, MCP versus A2A,
MCP is to communicate between
tools, agents and tools,
and A2A is for the
communication between agents.
So today, we are going to
work on this little project.
Actually, Olivier is going to
build it live in front of you,
which is really cool to see.
- [Olivier] A part of it.
- [Tiffany] Yeah, a part of it.
So when I was building my project
for my Dungeon and Dungeon
Master AI assistant,
I wanted it to be able
to do a lot of things.
Actually, if you start thinking about it,
the task is pretty tremendous
if you want an AI
assistant for Game Masters.
So the first thing I did is
that I had the orchestrator.
So that's the AI Game Master
that is talking to me,
but as I said before, it
has access to other tools
and other agents that are each specialized
into their different tasks.
So this agent that I'm talking to
has access to another agent
that will be the character
manager, for example.
So the character manager is
able to create characters
on the fly for you.
It has access to a database of characters,
so it can also get characters
for you from the campaign.
And it also has access to...
Oh, it just has access
to the database, right?
- [Olivier] It has tools to
access the database, yeah.
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
And a second agent
is the rule agent.
So the rule agent has access
to the full book of rules
of Dungeons & Dragons,
so it basically is a RAG.
So to make sure
that whenever I want to
do something in the game,
then my orchestrator is actually
able to ask the rule agent,
is this possible,
or in the mechanics of
the game, is this logic.
And finally, there is an
MCP server that we have
where we run a tool.
So it's a very simple tool.
I will show you.
I just needed my agent to be
able to roll dices for me,
like a Dungeon Master
usually takes decisions
as he rolls dices for you, like do D20
or other types of dices also.
And so I put this
function into a MCP server
and use the MCP protocol
to connect it to my agent.
Yeah, so that's what we'll build.
- [Olivier] Yeah, let's do it.
Let's do it.
- [Tiffany] Okay.
At the end of it, we'll show you
a more complex version of that
demo, but just to show you...
Oh, yeah.
- [Olivier] We build it, yeah.
- [Tiffany] Yeah, of course.
We are going to build this in
the timeframe of this session
thanks to an SDK.
So Strands Agents is a
software developer kit
for Python, but we'll announce maybe-
- [Olivier] Stay tuned this week.
- [Tiffany] Yes.
For building agents in
just a few lines of code.
And you'll see that this is literally
just a few lines of code,
which is really cool.
If you've built agents and
multi-agent workflows before,
you'll see how much simpler
this is now with Strands.
And it supports MCP
and A2A, which is great
because we've been waiting
for this for a while.
So this is what we use at AWS
internally, Strands Agents.
This is-
- [Olivier] Yeah, if you've
been using like Amazon Q,
that's using like Strands
Agents in the back.
- [Tiffany] Exactly.
- [Olivier] And that's when
we open sourced it like a few months ago,
but we've been using it at
Amazon Q for quite some time now.
- [Tiffany] Yeah, there's
a lot of internet tools
that actually have been built
with Strands internally.
So this also gives you an
idea of how robust this can be
'cause we run on huge
projects with multiple agents.
- [Olivier] And it's very easy to install.
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
So the first thing you need to do
is to install this library,
pip install strands-agents,
and then you're good to go.
Let's do this demo.
- [Olivier] All right,
demo time.
Ooh, nice.
Are you ready?
Yeah, okay, if you are ready
there, I'm gonna do it for you.
(chuckles) All right,
so here, I have my...
So it's Kiro, it's like my IDE,
and basically, have basically nothing.
I have like a app.py, an empty file,
and a requirement.txt
where I have my strands-agents
and strands-agents-tools.
We're gonna see later what it is used for.
But I wanted to, like, start
with like a blank project
so you can see from start how it works.
So first things I'm gonna do
is I'm going to import Strands, okay?
So I import the agent class,
so I'm going to create an agent object,
and then I'm gonna call it.
I'll say, "Good morning Vegas!"
Okay, let's do it.
So I have three lines of code.
Let's see if I execute them.
So what's happening now is like
it's replying, "Good Morning!
I'm actually Claude, an
assistant," blah blah, blah,
not in Vegas.
Okay, you're an AI.
You're not in Vegas.
But what you can see here is
like in three lines of code,
I've created an agent and
called an LLM of my agent.
So now you may wonder,
so what kind of LLM is
called in the background?
So you can actually print that out.
I can check my model here.
And if I code it again,
you see that by default,
Strand used Amazon Bedrock,
and here, by default, is
the claude-sonnet-4 LLM.
But we can change that, actually.
If I import the Bedrock model class,
I can create a new object,
BedrockModel, where I can
specify any Bedrock model
you can find on Amazon Bedrock.
If I do that, I'm just
gonna tell my agent.
So as a model, instead
of using the default one,
you can use, please, the
Bedrock model I just created.
So now, if I execute it
again, you can see that now,
it's using Amazon Nova Premier.
And you can play with
all the configuration.
If I want to change the
temperature, for example,
I wanna to select 0.7,
whatever, and you can send that
and you see that the temperature
is changed for my call.
And so if you look at these
Strands documentation here,
strandsagent.com, in the user guide,
you have the model providers here.
And actually, you have
access to a lot of models.
We saw that there's Amazon Bedrock.
You have Anthropic.
So if you're like an Anthropic
API key, you can use it.
So Strands is model agnostic
and even provider agnostic.
You have, like, Gemini, Llama.
You have a Mistral.
We're French, so let's promote that.
You have an API key for Mistral.
You can use it directly here.
You can use basically everything you want.
You can even use, like, Ollama here.
Say you have a provider for Ollama.
Do you know Ollama?
If you don't know Ollama,
basically, it's a tool
that allows you to
download a lot of models.
If you go under models
here, you have literally
a lot, a lot, a lot of models.
And what it allows you is it allows you
to, like, download these models.
They can go from like a few megabytes
to, like, a lot of gigabytes,
and to run them locally.
And it gives you access
to, like, an endpoint,
like an API endpoint so
you can call these models.
So you can even use that.
For example, if I import
like the Ollama class instead
and I say, okay, I'm just, like,
gonna create like an Ollama object,
I need to give it the host.
So here,
I have Ollama running on this here.
So it's running locally on my computer.
And then you specify the model idea.
So in Ollama, to run a model,
if I do that, it's going
to download the model
I'm running on my computer.
So I have a bunch already installed.
These are all the one I have installed.
You can see they can go from two megabytes
to a lot of gigabytes, and even,
like, way bigger than that.
So let me take like the
Llama 3.2, for example, here.
Oops.
Here you go.
And here, I'm gonna tell him,
okay, use the Ollama
model I just created here.
So if I run my code again,
you can see that now,
it's using Llama 3.2.
It's taking a bit longer because
it's running on my computer
so there's no cloud involved there,
and it's still replying to me.
So now, I use like a model
locally on my computer.
So okay, cool?
Yeah, that's cool.
- [Tiffany] But it's not yet an agent.
- [Olivier] It's an agent
but it's just running the LLM for now.
- [Tiffany] Yeah, it's an
instance of class agent,
but now, what's interesting is
that you can add tools to it.
- [Olivier] Yes, because
the good thing with LLM
is that they know a lot of things.
They've been trained on
a huge amount of data,
so you can ask them pretty much everything
and they will have an answer.
But sometimes, you're like
very simple questions,
like if I ask what time is it.
Very simple, right?
But if I ask that to my agent,
it's going to reply to me.
We don't need that anymore.
Okay, I don't have access to
the real time information,
so check your device, check your clock.
Thank you.
Ask an assistant, search
on your web browser,
or like, look at your watch.
Thank you very much.
So a very simple question,
but LLMs can't do that.
And that's where agents
are actually useful.
So you can give them access to tools,
and when they don't have the answer,
they will check if they have tools
that can help them answer this question.
And the good thing is Strands,
is that Strands comes
with a package of tools.
So if you go on the documentation again,
you have these tools menu here.
You have a community tools package.
If you don't remember,
that's the other package
I had in my requirements.txt.
And if you scroll down here,
you have access to a lot of tools,
some to manage memory,
to read and write files,
to do cron tasks, use_computer,
it's going to move your mouse
for you, doing HTTP requests,
read images, generate images, calculation.
There's one called current_time here.
So for example, we can use
this one to answer a question.
So if I do, okay, from
strands_tools, I want
to import current_time.
So now, I've imported the current_time,
and all I have to do is to tell my agent,
okay, you have access to all these tools.
So I put them in an array,
so right now, it's only current_time.
And if I ask again what time is it,
you will see that it's going to...
It's going to...
Yeah, it's going to call a tool.
So he is going to call
the tool current_time,
and then it's going to
reply to me, "It's nine."
Okay, let's...
In Las Vegas.
Let's be precise.
It's not 9:00 PM.
So I ask him again, it's
calling the current tool,
current_time tool, and
it's giving me the time.
So they can see that we enhanced
our LLM with tools thanks to the agent.
And you can do things pretty
cool, like file_write.
You can generate code.
I don't know if you use
like a code assistant
like Amazon Q, but
basically, you can recreate
like a very, very small,
like, version of it.
So for example, I have my
agent and I gave access
to, like, this tool,
file_write, and python_repl.
Python_repl is a tool that gives you
the possibility to execute Python code.
So I can do something pretty cool.
I can say, okay, let's write some code.
Like, write a function
in a file called
fib.py that generates the first
x ite
of Fibonacci.
Okay, and then execute it.
So I'm just asking that to my agent.
And if I execute it, what is happening
is that he's going to write the code
so that LLMs know how to write code.
That's okay.
Then it says,
"Okay, I need to write the
file because you asked me.
So I have this tool, write file."
So for some of the tools,
like write file, for example,
it's going to perform
actions on your computer.
There's a safeguard where it's asking you,
"Is it okay for me to write a file?"
You can bypass that
because in the CI/CD, you don't want that.
So you have like a environmental variable
that can allow you to
bypass these questions.
So I say yes.
So now, you can see that I
have this feedback.py file
that has been written, which is,
I trust it like the Fibonacci function.
And then again, the python_ripl one
is going to execute code.
So it's asking you, as a safeguard,
"Are you sure you want
me to execute code?"
And then it's going to execute the file
with the Python one just created.
So you can see that now, with
just like a few lines of code,
give it access to like a few
tools, it can create files,
execute Python code, and it's
actually pretty cool, right?
Yes, amazing. (laughs)
All right, so...
But we're not doing,
we're not here to, like, rewrite Amazon Q.
We're here to write a Game Master.
So when I write a Game Master,
I want access to other tools.
Like for example, Tiffany mentioned it,
we want a tool to roll dice.
So actually, if you ask
your LLM to roll a dice,
it's going to answer to you
because it's been trained
on data that roll dice,
but it's not like a natural random.
So we want to have a tool that roll dice.
And I don't know why the
Strands team didn't think
that having a roll dicing
tool was generic enough
to add it in the toolbox.
So, but I can actually write
a function to roll dice
with a number of faces.
Or I can write, or I can
ask an LLM, actually.
Write the function that...
It's telling five.
Come on, I'm going to write the code.
Roll a dice with a number of faces
given as a string.
Manage errors.
Okay, write me a function.
That's not the point of this talk.
Accept.
Okay, please indent it.
Nice.
So here, I have some code, okay?
And wouldn't it be nice to
just say, okay, I want my...
Whoop.
I want my function to become a tool.
That'd be cool, right?
But it's not that easy, unfortunately,
but it's not that much complicated.
I just have to import this
tool here from Strands
and then add a decorator on my function.
And just by doing that my
function here, roll_dice,
is becoming a tool.
So now if I ask it,
okay, roll a dice of six,
and I execute it, I execute it
here, it's going to
call my tool, roll_dice,
that I just wrote
and then, yeah, rolled
two on a dice of six.
But I can also ask,
like, roll a, like, 3D20,
which means three dice of 20 faces.
And while I'm doing that,
it's going to call three
times my roll_dice tool,
and then give me the
result and even the total
even though I didn't
ask for it, but bonus.
But you can see that it called
my roll_dice three times.
Pretty cool, right?
I just wrote a function, it became a tool.
Now as Tiffany mentioned,
there's two cases, two use cases
where I don't want my actual
tool to be written here.
There's one use case where
maybe someone else somewhere
wrote a tool that is already doing that
and put it behind an MCP server,
so I want to be able to,
like, use this MCP server.
Or nobody did that, and I'm
like, oh, I'm a nice guy
so I'm going to, like, put
this tool behind an MCP server
so anyone else can use it, right?
So let's see how we can do that.
I'm going to create a new file, mcp_dice.
Okay, and so the goal is to
take my roll_dice here...
Okay, remove that.
So my agent doesn't do much
but it has access to an MCP server here
that is going to be the one
that has my tool, right?
So to do that, I'm going to FastMCP.
So FastMCP is not part of Strands.
Strands is here to call MCP servers.
Strands is not meant to,
like, create MCP servers.
So FastMCP is a well-known library
that allows you to do a
lot of things with MCPs,
including creating servers.
So I'm going to create a server here.
I'm going to give it a name.
It's gonna be like DnD dice roll service.
Roll service.
Okay, I'm gonna...
You don't have to put
all this information,
but I'm gonna say, okay,
you run on my local host,
and I want you to run on port
8081, okay?
Okay, so I've done that,
and then I'm going to run my MCP server.
So I'm gonna say, okay,
I want you to run...
And MCP servers,
there are, like, three
ways of running them.
Either it's like on a CDIO
when you run them locally.
If you've done that with
Amazon Q, for example,
you can pull, like, NPX
or whatever, how you want to run them,
or SSE, which is like server
with pushing messages.
Or what I prefer is like
a streamable HTTP, so
it's like an HTTP stream.
So I'm going to specify the transport.
I'm gonna say, okay, I
want a streamable HTTP.
Let's do it.
Okay, so now, I have my
server, it's running.
All I need to do is to say,
okay, I want this function to be a tool.
So it works a bit like
in Strands, FastMCP.
It's like you put your
server and a tool decorator.
So by doing that, I have a MCP server,
normally, that's running.
All right, uh-huh.
Or not.
What did I do wrong?
Oh, it's run.
My bad, wrong function.
So here you go.
On the bottom right,
bottom left, here, I have my MCP server
running on my local host on the port 8081.
So now, what I want to do,
I want my Game Master agent
to be able to call this MCP server.
So I'm gonna import the MCP client class,
and because I'm using
like streamable HTTP,
also the streamablehttp function.
And so I'm gonna say, okay, my dice_mcp,
I'm going to create an MCP client.
I'll give the function streamablehttp,
and I only need to give it the URL.
So I'm gonna take the endpoint here.
What do you want?
You want paste?
Okay.
8081.
Okay, so now, I have
access to like a client MCP
to my MCP server, and
I'm gonna say, okay...
By just doing that, my
agent is going to be able
to call all the tools of my MCP server.
So let's running again.
Running it.
Yeah, FastMCP give you
a endpoint with 4/MCP.
My bad.
Okay, so you can see here,
you have some things
happening on the bottom left,
so it a request to list all the tools.
And then you can see that
it's calling the tool.
So you have some call to request.
You can see here that I'm
still calling my roll_dice.
Okay, first one didn't work,
but it's calling three times
my MCP server roll_dice tool,
and I have the results again.
So now, I was able to
externalize my MCP server.
And so my main agent doesn't do much,
but he has access to tools
through the MCP server, right?
That is cool?
- [Participant] Yeah.
- [Olivier] Thank you. (chuckles)
All right, so that's
basically, we have a function.
It's an MCP, okay?
It has a function as a tool.
And Tiffany mentioned another thing.
We want to have an agent
to manage our characters.
So now, what I want to do, I
want to create another agent
with whom my Game Master can communicate
to ask him to manage characters, okay?
So let's do that.
Let's create a new agent.
Okay.
Blank file.
So you remember how you create an agent?
Yes, we import agent class from
Strands and create an agent.
So here, I'm not gonna be the one
who call the agent manually.
It's going to be my other
agent who's going to call it.
So I need to give it a bit
of context of what it does.
So I'm gonna say, I'm
going to give it a name.
So it's like a management agent.
I'm going to give it a description.
Here we go.
Oh, description.
Okay, description is
like create and manage
Dungeon & Dragon characters
with a name, class, race,
statistics, and background.
And you can write and
read character files.
So in the final project
we're gonna show you after,
Tiffany mentioned that
we are using a database.
Here, for the sake of the demo,
because I don't have the whole afternoon,
I'm not gonna set up a
database for the purpose,
but what I'm gonna use
is I'm gonna use the
tools I have access to.
And remember, we have access
to file_read and file_write.
So for the purpose of this demo,
I'm gonna use read and write
on files as a database,
but in a normal project,
you're using a database to
manage your characters, right?
So I give access to the tools here.
I'm gonna say, okay, you
have file_read, file_write.
There you go.
And now, I have my agent.
Good?
Okay, so in order for this
agent to be able to be called
by my Game Master, I need
to make it a agent server.
So I'm going to create an A2A server here,
and let me create
an object, which I'm going
to give it the agent.
So on this A2A server,
agent to agent server,
I want this agent to run.
Again, I'm gonna say,
okay, I want you to run on my local host,
and I want you to run on another
port, like 8082, this one.
It was 8081, the first one, right?
Remember?
Yes.
Let's go with 8082.
And then I'm gonna say, okay,
I want you to run, all right?
So by just doing that,
I created an agent who
has access to tools.
I have an agent to agent server.
I'm just running it.
So that's running.
Let's run it.
Okay, I'm running my
agent, character agent.
So you can see it's running.
So I have my MCP here, server,
and my other agent running here.
So I'm going back to my main Game Master,
which, again, we don't want it
to have any, like, capacity.
It has to rely on other
agents and tools to work.
So I'm going to, okay,
import a A2A client to provider.
So for the MCP servers, you
need to create an MCP client
for every MCP server you have
because you have to get access
to their tools individually.
So a bit of a difference,
when you have access to an MCP server,
you can list all the tools
he has access to, okay?
And so you call a tool
from this MCP server.
When you call another agent,
you just send even a prompt
and the other agent,
which actually can use a different LLMs,
you can use another model
provider on this other agent,
but these other agents, you
don't know how it functions.
You don't know what
tools it has access to.
You don't know if it's
calling any other agents
because the purpose of
it is to run its own LLM,
to have its own, like,
reflection and iterations,
and then to give you an answer.
So that's why for the MCP,
we need an MCP client
for every MCP server.
For the agents, however,
it's a bit different.
I can say, okay...
I can say, okay, I created
like an A2A client provider,
and it takes an array of all the URLs
of all the agents you want to call.
So here, I have my agent which
runs on my 8082 port here.
And if you have others, other
agents, you basically just...
It's an array, so just put
them all here, all right?
We only have one now.
And so what I'm gonna do,
I say, okay, this provider, it has tools.
So now, the tools here, it's
not the tools of my agents.
It's the tools of the provider
that gives my agent access
to calling other agents.
Yeah, it's gonna make clear in a second.
It's gonna be clear in a second.
Okay, so now I have my MCP
client for my FCP server,
my A2A client to provider
to call my other agent.
Let's give it a try.
Create a
DnD character named...
Give me a name.
- [Participant] Steve.
- [Olivier] Steve.
Steve, who is a elf of the night.
Yes, let's be...
- [Tiffany] A night elf.
- [Olivier] Night elf.
Oh, it's okay.
Roll the dice to generate its
characteristics, then
save it in a file, okay?
So we're doing that.
So now, when you start
to have a good practice
when you have agents is
that when you start to have
like a lot of MCP or other,
like, tools or agents
you can communicate with,
a good practice is to
give it a system prompt.
So a system prompt is basically a prompt
that is gonna tell him what to do,
what it is responsible to,
but something I like to do
is to give it some guidances
in this system prompt.
So for example, here, I said,
okay, you are a DnD Game Master.
You have access to
different tools and agents.
Use them when you need them.
So like, you can draw dice.
You can create or manage characters.
You don't need to give it,
to tell him how to do it.
Just, like, you have
access to these things.
Just use them if you want.
And because we don't
want it to do anything
but only rely on these tools and agents,
just specify, like,
never answer by yourself,
always use the tools and/or agents, okay?
It's a good practice.
Let's do it.
It's gonna work, right?
It's gonna work.
- [Participant] Yeah.
- [Olivier] Yes, it's
gonna work. Okay, let's go.
So, what is happening?
Okay, it's calling my MCP
server list to request,
also doing some agent stuff.
So now, it's rolling dices for
ability score, some things.
It's going to generate, like,
six main abilities, so okay.
Strength, 11.
Average Steve.
A 12 in dexterity.
Eight for constitution.
Not the best.
Steve is quite intelligent.
That's good.
How many dice are we running?
Six in wisdom.
Ah, Steve is not the best
character. (chuckles)
And that's 10 for charisma.
Okay, so now you have the characteristic.
And you can see here...
Okay, so here, it's using
this tool, a2a_send_message.
And that's what I was talking
when I had the tools here.
So the tools here are these kind of tools
that allows my agent to
call the other agents.
So you can see at the bottom right
that my other agents had been called.
And again, he has access
to, like, a file_write tool,
and he's asking me if I'm okay to use it.
He's writing the tool, and
now, I have a file here,
Steve, night elf character,
with all its characteristics.
So you can ask him to write it as a JSON,
whatever you wanted.
I didn't specify anything,
so it's just like a file.
The same thing I can say,
okay, what can you tell me
about the character Steve?
And if I execute that,
again, okay, tools,
we don't need the tools,
normally, for this one.
You say, okay, I need to check
what agents are available
to help me get information
about characters.
You can see that you say,
okay, it's listing the agents.
Say, I have access to a
DnD character management.
It's sending a message.
And if I scroll up here,
you should see that,
tick, tick, tick, tick,
here, it's using the file_read tool.
So it know that he has a file about Steve.
He's reading it, sending the response,
and I have my agent here, my Game Master
who will receive all the
information about Steve.
And he even gives, like, some...
Like, Steve, like, he
relies on studying knowledge
rather than blah, blah, blah.
It gives its opinion.
But basically, we can see
that in a few lines of code,
I have my first agent,
another agent's tools.
Something I didn't mention
though, I forgot to mention,
when you have tools...
So here, it's pretty obvious.
I have a tool that is, the
function is called roll_dice.
I mean, it's pretty obvious.
So when I asked my agent to
roll a dice, it's going to check
and say, okay, there's a
function called roll_dice.
It makes sense that it's rolling dices.
Now, when you don't have...
Like, if I generate the docstring,
when you have multiple tools,
you have to use docstring.
So that's how, actually,
a agent discover tools,
using the docstring.
Let me just click that in.
So you need to give it a description,
you need to give it the arguments,
and then you return to examples here.
- [Tiffany] Um-
- [Olivier] So when you
have a lot of tools-
- [Tiffany] Yeah, this one makes sense.
- [Olivier] It's actually using
the docstring to use that.
And that's what I use
when I use the tools here,
the current_time.
The first time I said,
okay, give me the time,
and it gave me the time, like UTC.
But if you look at the code,
the source code of the current_time,
you can see that it has a docstring here,
and in the arguments, I
can give you the time zone.
So when I say in Las
Vegas, my Game Master agent
transcribed Las Vegas to the time zone
and called the tool current_time
with the time zone argument.
You wanted to add something?
- [Tiffany] Yeah, just,
so that's interesting.
When you write your tools,
actually, in the
documentation of Strands...
I don't know where it is.
- [Olivier] Yeah, it was there.
- [Tiffany] Oh, yeah.
You have examples of good practices,
and it's actually good to look at them.
You have examples of good practices
of how to write a good prompt,
'cause as Olivier said, this
is crucial into your design
because it uses this description
to know exactly what the tool is doing.
So there's a standard way of
writing those docstrings now.
And what I would recommend for you
is not to write it on your own,
but rather give the example
to your AI code assistant,
but make it generate by an AI
and give them the example
of the good practices
that is in the Strands documentation
and then give them the function
and they will write a
perfect docstrings for you.
But yeah, I, like, almost never
write my docstrings myself anymore.
- [Olivier] Yeah, most of the time,
it generates it by default so...
But yeah, it's a good,
it's a recommendation
to use the docstring because
that's what you're...
If you have, like, multiple tools,
it may not know which one to call,
so it's going to use the
docstring to know how it's called,
what it's doing, and what
parameters it needs to take
and the type of the parameters.
Good?
Okay.
- [Participant] I have a question.
- [Olivier] Sure, I don't
know how question works,
but yeah, I'm open to questions.
- [Participant] The code
is written from A2A agent,
but there's also concept for orchestration
in the Master Strand on the...
- [Olivier] Yeah, so
there's different ways
agents can communicate and work together.
Here, what we did is,
like, we just let the agent
to discover the other agents
and to go the one you want.
But if you go on the
Strands documentation,
there's different ways of creating agents.
You can create, like, workflows.
So basically, you said,
like, I have these agents
and I want them to always
be executed in that order.
And you can have, like, graphs of agents
saying, like, oh, these
graphs are connected.
These agents are connected.
You can have, like, swarms of agents.
Actually, if you go to...
Let's look at the agentic workflow here.
I think you have a code sample.
So here, you have, like,
an agent researcher,
an agent analyst, an
agent, like, writer agent.
And so you can just...
Tick, tick, tick, tick, tick.
Where is the...
Hmm.
It's somewhere, somewhere here.
All right.
I don't know exactly, but
there's the example somewhere.
You have...
Where is it?
But basically, yeah, you can do,
like, workflow
orchestrations, swarm graphs.
I think that's what you meant.
Hmm?
I mean, it's still going to use
like A2A underneath,
so the protocol, the standard that is used
is the standard protocol.
I don't know if that
answered the question.
Hmm?
The orchestration agent
is still going to use
like A2A, unless you run
all the agents on one code,
which you can do, actually.
You can run all the agents.
The agent to agent...
So what we did here,
okay, I think I got the question,
is that we ran the agent on, like, its own
on a server, right, with
its own, like, endpoints.
But you can, actually,
yeah, you can do like they do here.
It's like, okay, I have an agent here,
and I have another agent that
you write in the same file.
And so in that sense, here's
not going to go to use A2A
because they're all running
on the same source code.
I don't know if there's a
good practice or whatever.
The good thing when you have an agent
running on its own server
is that anyone can call it
and it's not just for you.
But that's the software design (chuckles)
or architecture question.
We have time.
Are we good?
All right.
So that's it for the live coding demo,
but we want to show you the final product.
Well, final product, still
a demo but a bit better.
Taking over?
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
- [Olivier] All right, should I run it?
So it's really tiny at the screen.
We realize this, but
this is just to show you
all of the different
servers that we're running.
So the first one that
Olivier was running was the-
- [Olivier] MCP server here.
- [Tiffany] The MCP server is here,
then here is the character agent.
- [Olivier] The rules agent.
- [Tiffany] The rules agent and then-
- [Olivier] Our Game Master.
- [Tiffany] The orchestrator.
And we have built a front-end application.
- [Olivier] Do you wanna show
the source code a bit before?
- [Tiffany] Yes, sure.
So-
- [Olivier] Tell me what to show.
- [Tiffany] So the MCP server
is pretty much the same
that we have shown during the demo.
The character, here is the character-
- [Olivier] Agent, yeah.
- [Tiffany] Agent.
So it has access to a database.
We have not created a database
together, but here it is.
You can see that we have
given the agent character
a bunch of different tools
to allow it access to
writing into the database,
reading the database,
and also, I think deleting things,
so it really is managing
this databases of characters
- [Olivier] And you can see
like, basically, each tool here
is literally just
wrapping a database call.
Just like say, oh, find character by name.
If we give it like a name,
there's the docstring.
And then the only important,
like, line of code here
is this one db.search.
It's just, like, wrapping,
like an API would wrap database code.
The tools are doing the same.
- [Tiffany] And all of that
wrapped into a tool decorator-
- [Olivier] Mm-hmm.
- [Tiffany] Too.
And we've made a massive
system prompt and description-
- [Olivier] Yeah.
- [Tiffany] Because you'll see
as you iterate through your tests,
prompt engineering is
still a thing. (chuckles)
You still need to make sure
that your prompt is actually,
like, describes well the different actions
that the agents can do.
Specifically, if you want a
certain format as an output,
or specifically, if you
wanted to standardize...
'Cause, for example, for
creating a character,
this is a pretty standard output for us.
We always want kind of the
same format and everything.
So we needed to be very specific
into what we wanted the
character agent to perform.
And also, this is the
system prompt of the-
- [Olivier] Game Master.
- [Tiffany] Game Master.
So the orchestrator also
has a massive system prompt.
This is through several
iterations of testing this demo
that we've come up with
this big system prompt.
I mean, it's a pain that you
have to go through, I guess.
Like, at the moment, testing
how your workflow goes
and iterating through different prompts
is the way you can reach
satisfactory outputs.
Here, we-
- [Olivier] Especially when you want
like an exact output type.
- [Tiffany] Yeah, so we came
up with this JSON format
specifically because we
had a front end at the end,
and we wanted to be able
to take each of the outputs
and put it in the right
place in your front.
So you're like...
At some point you're like,
if you want to generate
things automatically,
you kind of need your orchestrator
to answer to you in a standardized way.
And this prompt actually works
pretty well at the moment.
I'm saying this, but maybe
the demo's gonna fail, but-
- [Olivier] No, no, it's not.
- [Tiffany] So live demo, huh?
- [Olivier] No way.
Yeah, here, we wanted, like, the response
to be, like, used in web applications,
where, like, give it a response
based on this response,
which is like what the
Game Master is saying.
Give us, like, action that you can suggest
the user does after, the
player, give some details.
And if you roll some dice,
just tell us the kind of
dice you rolled, the result,
and the reason why you
had to roll the dice.
Should we try?
- [Tiffany] Yes, yes, yes.
- [Olivier] Okay, all right.
So Steve, we see that Steve,
Steve is a man.
He is a dwarf this time,
random, and he's a cleric.
Okay, so I'm gonna take these...
They draw all of my Game Master.
Let's go.
- [Tiffany] Okay, so
as we launch the game,
the AI Game Master has the
instruction to launch a campaign
and create the character, Steve,
with the characteristics that we gave him.
So what is Steve?
It's a human?
- [Olivier] No, he's a dwarf.
- [Tiffany] Dwarf.
Dwarf cleric.
- [Olivier] Dwarf cleric, yeah.
- [Tiffany] So you'll see
that there are different calls
that have been made by
the game orchestrator.
- [Olivier] Like, the
dice tool has been called.
The character agents has been called.
And it generates, like, an answer
and send it back to the game.
So let's see what we have here.
You want to read what it says?
Welcome to the realm, Steve.
Your English is better than mine.
- [Tiffany] Well, okay.
(Olivier laughs)
Welcome to the realm, Steve.
Your dwarven boots crunch on
frost-covered cobblestones
as you approach the
flickering torch light.
This is pretty cool.
Like, you can read the entire thing.
I've played so many
different games with this.
This is pretty cool.
So we have three...
We asked the orchestrator
to generate three different
options that you can click
if you don't wanna type.
So let's investigate.
- [Olivier] Yes.
- [Tiffany] Investigating is cool
'cause it usually leads to
dice rolls, as you can see.
- [Olivier] Okay, we have
the response already.
- [Tiffany] So what was the...
Investigate the strange sound
coming from the alley behind the tavern.
And as the Game Master is rolling dices,
we can get the results of the rolled dices
and put them in our front application.
It's cool.
- [Olivier] Or you can
type whatever you want,
if it's like, run away,
go home.
I don't know. (chuckles)
It's gonna be the same.
Do you want us to try the rule thing?
- [Tiffany] Well, so this is where we know
the boundaries of our demos.
- [Olivier] Retreat.
- [Tiffany] Let's try to make
it invoke the rule agent.
Say something that has no sense.
Like...
- [Olivier] Fly to the
moon, take your light saber,
and kill the monsters.
- [Tiffany] So basically,
if you wanna do something
that has no sense in the
mechanics of the game,
usually, the Game Master will be like,
"Hey, you can't do this."
But we'll see if...
So there's an error message, first.
(Tiffany chuckles)
- [Olivier] Yeah.
- [Tiffany] But...
- [Olivier] Okay, let's ask him instead.
Like, can I go to the moon?
Can I,
can I fly to the moon
and back with my rocket?
Let's see.
- [Tiffany] It should
request the rule agents.
- [Olivier] Aha.
- [Tiffany] Okay.
- [Olivier] Yeah, something's happening.
Yeah.
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
- [Olivier] And the rules.
- [Tiffany] Oh, it's working.
- [Olivier] Yeah.
- [Tiffany] I'm so happy. (laughs)
- [Olivier] For the rules
agent, what we did that,
like, we took the PDF of the game,
we put it in a vector
database, so it's like a RAG.
And so that's how our
agent is able to read it
and say, like, "Steve,
you're still bleeding
in a dark alley facing a dangerous bandit.
There's no rocket in the
medieval fantasy world of DnD.
You are a first level draw
of cleric with," whatever.
- [Tiffany] 23 feet of walking-
- [Olivier] No, no, no, travel.
No sci-fi technology, sorry.
- [Tiffany] Well, I mean that, that's good
'cause it's actually arguing
as to why you can't do
the things you want to do.
But yeah, it's actually
checked the rules of the games
to see if you actually could not do this.
So yeah, this is really cool.
So as you can see in, like,
a short amount of time...
Do we still have time?
- [Olivier] Yeah, well...
- [Tiffany] Yeah, we are able to build
multi-agentic workflow
with the Strands SDK.
Do you wanna add anything else to...
Does anybody want to try something?
Or...
- [Olivier] Let me check
because you should be
able to find these...
Tick, tick, tick.
Okay, just for those who
want to see this in action,
if you go on AWS Samples,
you have these
sample-once-upon-agentic-ai.
This is usually a workshop, but here...
So by default, you won't
see anything on this branch,
but if you go on the solution-v3 here,
you have all the source code
to run the demo we just ran.
And if you go on the UI branch,
you even have access
to the UI that we used,
which is like an another application,
so feel free to go check.
- [Tiffany] Let me share QR codes-
- [Olivier] Yes.
- [Tiffany] With you.
So if I go back to the presentation,
so those were, if we failed, we had
(Olivier chuckles)
video recorded-
- [Olivier] Not good videos.
- [Tiffany] Of the demo.
- [Olivier] It worked.
The demo worked.
- [Tiffany] Yeah, it did work.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Yeah.
Whew.
Okay.
- [Olivier] Phew.
- [Tiffany] So here are the
code samples that you can get,
also, the Strands documentation
if ever you're interested.
And if you have any questions,
we still have a little bit of time.
So thank you very much for your attention.
(audience applauds)